I'm very sad to have to report this
update but we're just hearing from West
Midlands police that three boys have
died after falling into the lake here
yesterday we're told the boys were aged
11 10 and 8 years old the police say
they were rushed to hospital after being
pulled from the water but sadly they
could not be revived now we're told that
a fourth boy who is aged just six years
old remains in a critical condition in
Hospital West Midlands police say
they've been working alongside
colleagues from the fire and ambulance
service they say searches the lake are
continuing as they try to establish
exactly what happened and if indeed
anyone else fell into the water they say
their thoughts are with the families of
these boys and they're asking people not
to speculate about what happened or
share any footage of this Dreadful
incident so confirmation there from West
Midlands police that three young boys
aged 11
ten and eight have sadly lost their
lives after falling into this icy lake
here in solihull yesterday afternoon
police are continuing to search I don't
know if you can see behind me you might
be able to make out through the trees
there there are some police officers
chest deep in the water as we speak
there is still ice on the water it's
bitterly cold this has been a major
search and rescue operation we know that
the four children were pulled out of the
water after Emergency Services were
alerted yesterday but there were fears
for their health because we were told
they were all in cardiac arrest and
Witnesses saw paramedics performing CPR
before they were taken on blue lights to
nearby hospitals so just to reiterate
that very very sad breaking news that
three boys aged 11 10 and 8 years old
have sadly lost their lives with a
fourth boy age six remaining in a
critical condition in hospital we do
know that a local primary school has
remained closed today because of this
and that staff and pupils there will be
getting specialist support
to deal with what's happened here